[Music]
welcome to the program we have maybe the
best show we've ever done and quite
possibly not
that guy was down with what are you
waving at me sir a bobble hair at all
pass that down somebody
okay that's this is just insulting
I love this but what's with my mouth
here what's with my getting tight on
that iyo why I made you uh thank you
very much here take that pic that's okay
thank you everyone everyone please pass
your handmade gifts forward but only if
they're in your likeness yeah they have
other ones welcome to the show
what a great crowd tonight we're gonna
have a good time and who's excited about
the Superbowl you ready I heard they say
in an interview yesterday Madonna said
she's nervous about performing at the
Super Bowl
Madonna's nervous yeah she's also not
happy that they're calling it the scary
cougar halftime show love the name who
you for do you care who wins I'm for
Madonna and you'll win all right
I'd have you heard this supermodel
Gisele Bundchen wants people to yeah
Wow that's all apparently I have to say
no supermodel Gisele Bundchen wants
people to pray for her husband Tom Brady
to win the Super Bowl yeah yeah and in
response God said you know what I think
I've done enough for Tom Brady
you think about it only he had a better
life she got a thirst with that face and
that wife she did get an answer though
which supermodels when they talk to God
they get answered it's true the best
Republican presidential race has moved
on to Nevada did you know that after
losing in Florida Newt Gingrich is now
campaigning very hard in Las Vegas Newt
is in Las Vegas Gingrich said he loves
Las Vegas because it has two of his
favorite things buffets and wedding
chapels make a bobblehead of that joke
rapper Canaan is upset because MIT
Romney used his rap song during Romney's
victory speech in Florida
yeah and he's mad about yeah Kenan said
that's the last time I write a song
called me so Mormon
and he likes it too
they've chosen a new voice to play Dora
the Explorer now and I just want to say
thank you for the opportunity kids I
will not let you down vamanos
we did it backpack look nothing too hard
at that I know what's going on over here
I don't know if you heard this they're
coming out with a new updated version of
the ancient sex manual the Kama Sutra
yeah I think I think they may have made
it too modern because the first position
it describes is the dougie I don't get
that joke at all half an hour before the
show I'm trying that out on interns no
no that should be okay
this dougie what is this dougie
can we get a young person in here to
find out if that's funny yeah I'm 77
years old and proud of it
Katy Perry's in the news it's being
reported that Katy Perry Katy Perry may
be releasing a 3d concert movie 3d
concert movie yeah and instead of 3d
glasses you'll get protective goggles
now he's not liking it it's just here
when the hair moves that little